What
that is
so
of
you
here.
[Silence]
Quran and right these are all
descriptions of the Quran.
Now, one of these descriptions is that
the Quran is a
it is a reminder. It reminds them does
it remind the person of everything
that is relevant to the human being's
existence? It reminds you of who you
are. Reminds you of where you came from.
Reminds us of where we are going. It
reminds us of who we belong to. It
reminds us of what we are headed to. It
reminds us of what we are supposed to be
doing. And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
asks rhetorically
about those disbelievers
why what is it that repels them so
harshly from the remembrance the
reminder.
He says subhanahua
for
General.
[Silence]
Neverch.
Mecca
wasallam.
[Silence]
foreign.
Huh?
[Silence]
establish
men
[Silence]
Notice here how They are repulsed by the
Quran. It's not just that they hear it
and they say, ", this is this is
this is not true." Imagine imagine how
many how many hacks you have heard in
your life. How many crazies have you
heard in your life? people that claim to
be prophets, people that claim to be
messengers, people that claim to be
gods, people that claim to be all kinds
of things, right? And you've heard them
before, you've seen them. Do you really
sit and think about them deeply? Or is
it as soon as
they're gone, they are out of sight, out
of mind? Immediately. As soon as you
turn the TV off or change the channel or
as soon as you, you know, get your fill
of them in a day or two, they're gone.
They're gone from your mind. They don't
affect your life.
That's different than the Quran. The
Quran is unavoidable.
The Quran is intrusive.
The Quran when you hear it, it changes
you and they can't get it out of their
mind. So how are they repulsed by the
Quran? Allah gives us imagery here. He
says, "So what is wrong with them? What
is the matter with them? They are so
repulsed by the remembrance of Allah, by
the Quran, as if they are wild asses or
zebras. We call them zebras if they're
in Africa. They are called wild asses if
they are in Syria and the Sahara desert
desert and northern Africa. They don't
have stripes, but they're the same.
Look, these are wild donkeys, right?
When we say the word donkey in English,
usually it means domesticated.
They're gray in color. You ride them.
Those are haram to eat. That is a
different thing. What Allah is
mentioning here are the wild asses
that are called zebras.
if they have stripes, if they don't,
they're referred to linguistically in
the dictionary as wild asses. They are
homor.
And have you ever seen on these
nature documentaries how these wild
asses and zebras how they get startled
when a when a lion comes to take them
down? You see how they kick up dust and
they run all over the place and all they
care about is getting away. That imagery
that every one of us has seen. Allah
says, "So why are they so repulsed from
the remembrance
as if they are wild asses that have been
startled startled by a lion chasing
them?"
startled by a lion in chase or startled
by a hunter because the word
in the Arabic language it means lion or
it means hunter both meanings are
correct. So if you imagine that lion
when it comes out to you know to get
the the the wild zebra or what have it
its prey how they kick up dust and they
start to scream and yell that is how
they are acting when the prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam walks by
that's how they act when they hear the
words
Why is that? Because that means that
they know in their hearts that this is
the truth from Allah. Otherwise, it
wouldn't be such a big deal. How many
hacks, how many village idiots exist in
the world? We don't worry ourselves with
them. We see them, we laugh at them, we
might bring them up once or twice, but
then we ignore them. I mean, shucks,
even if he's our own president, even if
he's our own , you know, governor or
senator and he acts a we
think, ", this guy's a hack." And we
just forget about him. We don't get
obsessed with him. When do we get
obsessed? We get obsessed when we think
or know that this has real serious
consequences in our lives. And that is
how it is for the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. They are running and fleeing
from him as if they are startled wild
asses that have been that are being
chased by a lion out to split spill and
shed their blood.
Why is that? Why are they behaving in
this way? Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
What is their response when the
remembrance of the Quran comes to them?
They say
we should Why isn't it that each of us
is given a book? I tell you what, if
each of us is given a book, then we'll
believe. Why is it that the book is only
given to Muhammad? Why isn't it that
every single one of us is given a book?
If every one of us is given a book, well
then believe. Wouldn't that be better?
Isn't Allah able to send down a book
upon everyone? So Allah says
they request and they say the only thing
stopping them from believing is that
each of them has not been given his own
open book. He's not being spoonfed
every single thing. Notice how the book
isn't just given a book. No,
not only is it not enough that the book
is given to each of them, but it needs
to be opened for us and it needs to be
spoonfed to us and we as if they are the
the masters and the messengers and
prophets, they are the slaves.
This is an incredible amount of
entitlement.
But is that really why they are not
believing? Is that really what's
stopping them? They say, "If we were
given a book, if we were given an open
book, we would believe." Is that really
what's stopping them? Allah says in the
subsequent verse,
[Silence]
Subhanah.
He says rather
it is that they do not fear the
hereafter. That is really the root of
the problem. This statement of Allah
You know what they say that that money
is the root of all evil. That's not the
root of all evil. The root of all evil
is not fearing the hereafter.
That is the root of all evil.
He says
this is at the end of
how many crimes did Allah mention of
them in this chapter?
the people of the hellfire
they said we were not
we didn't pray.
We didn't give to those who were poor.
[Silence]
All of these things, all of these
crimes, all of these misdeeds, all of
these
illnesses and ailments. What is the root
cause?
It's because they do not fear the
hereafter.
If a person doesn't fear standing in
front of Allah, if a person doesn't fear
being judged, all evil will come and
follow that belief.
When a person, even if a person believes
in the hereafter, but he's not afraid of
the hereafter, notice the wording.
It's not just believing in the
hereafter.
It is fearing the hereafter. Fearing
that you're not good enough, fearing
that you're going to be asked. Fearing
that your deeds are not accepted,
fearing that your repentance is not
accepted, fearing that your misdeeds are
not overlooked. If you don't have that
fear, all evil will follow such a
belief.
That is the root of all evil is not
fearing the hereafter. Even if a person
believes in it, they have to fear it.
They have to fear standing in front of
Allah. Fear that just maybe they're
inadequate or that their inadequacies
will lead to their demise. That is what
is necessary to make a man better. If a
person doesn't have that fear,
say what you will of subsequent evils.
[Silence]
Every evil is built upon love of the
dunya and a lack of fear of the
hereafter.
[Arabic recitation]